[Music]
preparing food takes an amazing amount
of attention to detail
food is one of the great equalizers it
offers an incredible opportunity for
laughter for deep discussion for
contemplation problem solving
when I am cooking the goal is to have
someone eat and have their senses
awakened and take them on a journey to
ReDiscover the dish each time they take
a bite
foreign
S I am the chef and owner of virtue
restaurant Daisy's po-boy and Tavern
Mustard Seed takeout kitchen and Top
This mac and cheese
[Music]
it's real oh it just needs to be served
yes sir my man
let's talk about room
I decided to invite friends from the
chef's Community into my home in the
tradition of a red beans and rice dinner
traditionally found in New Orleans
I grilled chicken Ash roasted rutabaga
roasted chicken
additionally I seared American red
snapper I did a lima bean and mustard
green dish alongside of that with
coconut rice
[Music]
ah when I think back to what I saw most
as a kid it was southern food
I feel very connected to that space when
I'm cooking
I Look to pay a lot of homage to those
that cooked before me
to think who was the person that
discovered collard greens and thought to
cook them in a way that was healing and
in a way that will provide a way of
survival
[Music]
the first thing I do when preparing
chicken on the grill is I generally
brine it for a day I chose to use a
Tabasco brine it allows me to season the
chicken really evenly I take the
backbone out because when grilling
chicken I like to have a flat surface
much like people would do if they were
doing brick chicken
bring the chicken up to room temperature
then I move into lighting the grill
cooking logs down to coals
brush the chicken with oil
season it lightly with salt and pepper
and I apply the chicken onto the grill
breast and leg side down
I was really lucky to get beautiful
American red snapper
I prepared the Snapper by filleting it
off of the balm
there's almost always still a few scales
and usually the most unlikely thing for
me to do at home but it's one of those
necessary evils and the reason it's
unlikely for me to do at home is because
the scales get everywhere
once the Snapper is filleted and I've
removed all visible scales I checked the
fillets to make sure that there are no
remaining bones and if so I use fish
tweezers
to remove those bones and then I portion
the Snapper into basically a pretty
uniform size
for a fillet that doesn't really want to
be uniform
I'd season them with salt and pepper
seared them to get the skin crisp and
serve them garnish with scallions
[Music]
as a child I was fun loving I was
energetic curious
I lived in a home that was safe that was
encouraging that contained rigor
I was working in kitchens as a means to
an end and I had the opportunity to meet
a chef Michael cornick and he was so
passionate about food it became
infectious
I worked at MK for 20 years
[Music]
rutabagas always have a wax coating on
them
and so I take the rutabaga and I lay
them directly on top of the coals and
they look like charcoal by the time
they're done
[Music]
if I was to describe a rutabaga I would
describe it as what a turnip wants to be
rutabagas have a natural sweetness to
them
the rutabaga is then dressed with
sunflower seeds
arugula
midnight moon cheese which is a firm
goat cheese
[Music]
I generally soak my beans overnight in
this case I was using dried lima beans
I started with diced onion red bell
pepper
and sliced garlic
I sweat the onions
the garlic then I add the red bell
peppers
at that point I stir the beans in
and I add turkey stock
I simmer the beans until they're about
80 percent done at that point I add
enough mustard greens where there is
about a 60 ratio of mustard greens to
beans once they wilt
[Music]
hi everyone
virtue daisies
Mustard Seed kitchen and now Top This
mac and cheese and we're all designed to
fill a void I strongly believed that the
world was craving kindness and it
continues to Crave kindness and we
wanted to have a space that is
considered safe space
that is
culturally alive and vibrant
that tells the stories of The Narrative
of the black experience through food and
music
and textures and art
and we wanted to harness that in one
space
[Music]
how you doing
good did you make this
we want places that feel inclusive
it's just surrounded by
Black Culture that's what sets the table
I appreciate you man I don't know what's
black on I appreciate y'all man
[Music]
I took a warm pan
I sweat diced sweet potatoes added par
cooked Carolina gold rice and I
moistened that rice with coconut milk
fold it in the coconut milk loosen the
rice with a little bit of the turkey
stock that we had reserved and finished
it with salt and pepper
I thought this particular meal was an
incredible opportunity for me to invite
friends from the chef's Community into
my home
to just let our hair down
get a chance to connect
you know I think that people that are at
your dinner table should be people that
you respect
I think that's part of the experience oh
that's grandma [ __ ] right there
like really how many times do we get a
chance to do this
never right right that's the other part
all right so Fellowship is important
we take a lot of pride in making sure
that we leave the industry better than
it was when we found it
and part of our contribution is making
sure that young Cooks can see chefs that
look like them and owners and operators
that look like them in an effort for us
all to believe that you know the world
is not one-dimensional it's not made for
some and not others and that that the
stigmas are put behind us
and that's important to me
oh good